herzlich willkommen zurück zu finden
nach acht der top der schlagzeilen macht
heute waren schon einige dabei und jetzt
kommt's béla anda ich habe mich heute
auf gerichte über sehr schockiert wie so
viele denke ich heute kimmig spaltet mit
seinem verhalten gerade die nuts und
gibt denjenigen wasser auf die mühlen
die ihre verschwörungstheorien rund und
rund um das thema hinten in den sozialen
netzwerk mit furor verbreiten das war
sicherlich nicht gemixt absicht gemisch
ist eine herausragende spieler stammt
wieder beim fc bayern und bei der
nationalmannschaft und er ist ein profi
der sich wie kaum ein anderer um seinen
körper kümmert also um die nährstoffe
und mineralien ganz genau analysiert was
er da zu sich nimmt und deswegen war in
den letzten sechs jahren bis auf einen
meniskusschaden und eine kurze grippe
nur vier tage verletzt oder krank
insofern verstehe ich dass er überlegt
was er da in und an seinen körper an ist
aber sich für eine week corona kampagne
einspannen oder beziehungsweise dafür
freiwillig zu melden
wissen dass er die wichtigste maßnahme
krone zu kicken nämlich sich impfen zu
lassen komplett ablehnen bisher
zumindest das geht gar nicht und am
meisten aber stört mich in vier stadien
in deutschland gilt die sogenannte zweig
regel also da kommt man nur rein wenn
man entweder geimpft oder entsprechend
genießen ist oder nicht wenn man
getestet ist auch nicht mit einem pc
jetzt in stuttgart so in wolfsburg so
dass in leipzig so und das ist in
freiburg so aber was heißt das konkret
im trend also bei seinen spielen
auswärts spielten diesen stadien munter
auf den stadien in den stadien herum
aber diejenigen die ihn sehen wollen die
fans die getestet sind genauso wie er
sie kommen nicht rein ich finde das geht
gar nicht entweder sagen diese
fußballboss in den stadien haltung und
erlauben den menschen die getestet sind
den zugang genauso wie sie kimmig das
erlauben oder sie wenden das recht muss
im stadion gilt auch für diejenigen die
auf dem platz sind an das heißt beim fc
bayern konkret dass wir nicht spielen
kann auch seine vier uns namentlich
öffentlich nicht bekannten mitspieler
wahrheit gilt aber auch der fc bayern
ist im moment
in einer form dass sie das sicherlich
bei den auswärtsspielen in wolfsburg in
freiburg in leipzig und auch in
stuttgart werden verkraften fehler ich
finde es reicht langsam mit dem
draufhauen auf herrn kimmig das geht
jetzt seit tagen so und was da passiert
finde ich ist ein regelrechter pranger
der in richtung kimmig geht zum beispiel
oli deppendorf
bekannter polit interview der ard
mittlerweile im ruhestand der heute
getwittert warum spielt der ungeimpfte
job käme ich eigentlich noch in der
mannschaft von bayern münchen bis zur
impfung sollte er nicht mehr aufgestellt
werden was ist den bayern
verantwortlichen wichtiger vorbild oder
profit er wohl letzteres also erst mal
das lied eppendorf in den termiten
stranded der trend
deppendorf und ich finde das ist
wirklich ein skandal wie dieser mann
dort an den pranger gestellt wird für
etwas was seine persönliche entscheidung
sein sollte ich gebe dir recht natürlich
diese kampagne das ist alles absolut
unglücklich und kritikwürdig aber die
debatte die daraus entstanden ist die
hat jeden jedes boden verloren jedes maß
verloren und man fragt sich wirklich was
es eigentlich in deutschland los dass
wir immer einzelne leute brauchen auf
die drauf gehauen wird bis sie nicht
mehr können ich würde mich nicht wundern
wenn joshua kimmig sagt also diese
debatten kultur die es in deutschland
gibt immer mit dem finger auf ihn zeigen
immer noch weitermachen und das nicht
einmal kritisieren sondern 10 x 15 x 20
x die mediale debatte die gar nicht
aufhört also diese jagd auf ihn ich
könnte mir vorstellen dass er irgendwann
sagt ich habe keine lust mehr auf
deutschland ich zu hektisch heute noch
weitergehen ganz kurz fehler aber ich
sage ganz klar ich finde dass herr kim
ich überhaupt kein fehler begangen hat
also er selber sagt er ist nicht geimpft
das ist doch sein gutes recht und damit
holt er übrigens auch die bürger ab die
sich vielleicht auch nicht impfen lassen
wollen und man sieht an dieser
debattenkultur dass wir endlich war es
in deutschland ändern müssen ich bin zum
beispiel kämpft wäre das jetzt wie immer
damit jetzt nicht gleich der shitstorm
über mich einen bericht über league
schon ein kokon der zertifikate
mitzunehmen um diese meinung vertreten
zu können und da müssen uns doch ganz
klar überlegen was ist in diesem land
los dass ich sage zum glück bin ich
geimpft ich kann jetzt nicht beispringen
sonst würde ich es nicht tun und ich
glaube deswegen sollte man auf und auf
dem ring zu hacken weil sonst trauen
sich noch weniger menschen in
deutschland ihre meinung zu sagen der
wert liegt ja schon laut dem institut
unter 50
es gibt ja je zwei verschiedene themen
diese meter thema das meter zehn mal was
du ansprichst und was ihr beide
anspricht im guten wie geben wir müssen
mit der statik aber es ist doch nicht
nur so dass es nur kritik gibt an joshua
kimmig jubeln ja ganz viele menschen
endlich sagt es mal einer und endlich
sagt mal jemand da gibt es risiken und
nebenwirkungen mögliche deswegen tue ich
mir das nicht an und der mann ist auch
noch nationalspieler aber in welcher
welt leben wir in einer welt in der
immer mehr politisiert wird das gilt für
unternehmen das gilt für unternehmer das
gilt aber auch für polen fußballstars
die wie politiker mit allem was sie tun
öffentlich sind und wenn ich
nationalspieler bin und da kommen wir
zum kern und mich für eine anti kroner
kampagne einsätze wissend dass ich nicht
geimpft bin dann sollte ich das nicht
tun weil ich wissen muss oder mehr in
kluger berater zumindest mir das sagen
muss dass man auch mein freund da kommt
nämlich dieser shitstorm also das hat er
ja nicht transparent gemacht sondern es
kam im nachhinein erst heraus als erna
ritzmann kroner positiv war also das
muss man wissen wenn man sich in die
öffentlichkeit begibt das alles was man
tut öffentlich ist das gilt mittlerweile
auch für fußballprofis
teile ich aber klar ist es andererseits
auch so und das kann ich auch verstehen
muss man auch sagen die art und weise
der shitstorm es dass er sich jetzt da
noch super rechtfertigen muss dafür dass
der vorhalt ist zu sagen okay
kommunikativ nicht geschickt die
kampagne mitzumachen das würde ich
teilen aber bei vielen so wie es auch in
dem zitierten tweet war schwingt ja mit
zusagen wie unsolidarisch sich nicht
impfen zu lassen ja ich finde gut wir
haben die große impfkampagne gemacht
werden dafür und das ist auch okay ich
habe mich auch dafür aber ich habe auch
respekt davor wenn leute sagen sie
wollen es nicht machen und insoweit kann
man ihm genau so wie es analysiert ist
natürlich kommunikativ irgendwie ein
vorhalt machen aber ich finde auch wenn
man fußball nationalspieler ist muss man
sich nicht dafür an pranger stellen
lassen wenn man sich entscheidet sich
nicht impfen zu lassen das halte ich für
deinen etwas überzogen auch wenn ich
selbst auch als politiker dafür werbe
sage ich trotzdem
da kann es nicht sein dass ihr dafür an
wie ist das bei ihnen der fraktion es
gab ja auch mal die statistiken wie viel
prozent in den jeweiligen fraktionen
geimpft sind gibt es in der
unionsfraktion müssen jetzt ja auch
keine namen nennen aber leute die auch
sagen wie zum beispiel herr aiwanger von
den freien wählern in bayern sein nein
wir bleiben dabei wir lassen uns nicht
immer so ich wusste es nicht ich kann
jetzt keinen kollegen aktiv aber ich
kann es hier mal enthüllen ich habe hier
schon denn das männchen aus dem robinson
club quasi geworden
aber dann ist mir das nicht mehr durch
doch das soll durch fest sein wo der
unsere erzählt das ist der zutritt für
die für die bundestag also das schlafen
zweijährigen also habe ich das müssen
wir kurz erklären führende zuschauer
also das wurde heute verteilt an
diejenigen die geimpft sind nein auch
für also geimpft gewesen getestet man
musste sich heute sozusagen dann das
geht auch morgen noch bis 11 uhr aber
wir haben gesagt weil es im plenarsaal
natürlich alles ein bisschen beengt ist
morgen wir aber den plenarsaal nutzen
wollten was ich richtig finde man kann
nicht sagen wir machen die bundestags
konstituierung irgendwie vor jedes mal
übern und das ist auch meine firma
schwarz rot gold gold gold
konstituierende sitzung damit die abda
ist auch
triebwagen logistischer aufwand und ich
finde das aber gut dass man so gemacht
hat und am ende hat man die ard will
aber wohlgemerkt auf das haben wir schon
gehört in der konstituierenden sitzung
sprechen wir auch über die
geschäftsordnung morgen wie sich das
gehört klingt technisch aber dann wird
die ab den natürlich auch alles im
umfeld mit corona wieder in zweifel
ziehen also das sind auch debatten was
ich aber wissen sie das jetzt vier jahre
tragen nein das ist jetzt das ist jetzt
grund für die konstituierende sitzung
morgen und ich habs jetzt aus
logistischen gründen um morgen ich in
einer schlange zu stehen schon heute
gemacht und von der durch festigkeit
werde ich mich morgen früh immer über
mich schon ein bisschen angegriffen aus
und jetzt ist es ist frisch von frisch
von der sendung haben da viel dran runde
zu
betreiben